I usually had some frogs with me this
guy came running up to me and he started
to point my face he goes I'm sick and I
want some drugs you're gonna give him to
me I started walking away from him and
the next thing you know I see him out of
the corner of my eye came running up to
me with the knife
I was like did I just get stabbed here I
have to fight this guy
I sort of punch him in the face as I was
punching him in the face he was trying
to stab it felt like I had no more power
in me I had to get it back together and
hit him again was just giving everything
I had I was hitting him as hard as I
could in order to get that night that he
had away from I was fighting for my life
he was trying to kill me the very last
punched by him it's far isn't it and he
fell on the ground knife went flying out
of his hand I kind of knocked him out
a couple guys came out and grabbed me
and they're like hey you're bleeding all
over the place come in here and lay down
these guys wrap me up with some rags and
t-shirts and stuff a couple of the guys
are looking at me and they're like
you're gonna be okay
all the inmates were like don't go down
there to the clinic and don't go telling
on anyone
look what doesn't
I needed some stitches but you know if I
would have gone down there then I would
have been a snitch I was so tired
eventually a bleeding slowed down
I felt like it was the lowest point of
my whole time being in there I didn't
know what to do it was just a big mess
I'm a white guy in a Mexican prison the
whole time it was a fight just to stay
alive I saw some of the people dying
there
I've witnessed three four separate
occasions so I feel good being stabbed
to death
keep on actually dying
and it's not thing that you ever really
want to see